et has your quick look at the cover  stars hitting the newsstands here's  Alicia Keys on the front of Glamour's  March activism issue inside revealing  how being a mother has changed her I  think what I love the most is the way it  makes me think about what's important  and what's not important what it is that  I'm teaching through example and what it  is that I was taught that I don't want  to teach and that's Gigi Hadid on the  cover of british vogue for the second  time it's just a dream come true inside  she poses with her younger brother Anwar  Hadid and opens up about her private  life and the movie nights with boyfriend  Zayn Malik I'm always like babe let's go  to a movie then I fall asleep halfway  through and he's like you've seen the  first half of every movie out there and  you have no idea how any of them end  you